so today a small number of passengers
stuck in airport lounges across the
country looked up at one of those
televisions bolts to the ceiling and
noticed something weird
Don Lemon the star of CNN this morning
was not at work and to be fair sometimes
a vacation is just a vacation but we
can't help notice that Don lemon's
absence comes just today after he laid
bare his utter contempt once again for
his co-anchors Poppy Harlow and Caitlin
Collins
now the passive aggressive stick is
pretty fine-tuned and also getting kind
of obvious lamon pretends to attack
Republicans yesterday was Nikki Haley as
a way of attacking his co-hosts he
thinks he's getting away with it but
yesterday morning he made his to stay in
a little too obvious watch this I think
it's the wrong road to go down she says
people you know politicians or something
and not in their Prime Nikki Haley is in
a prime sorry when a woman is considered
being a prime in her 20s and 30s and
maybe 40s that's not according to me
Prime for what it depends I mean it's
just like Prime if you look it up it'll
if you look if you Google when is a
woman in a prime it'll say 20s 30s and
40s I don't know I'm not saying I agree
with that so I think she has to be
careful about saying that you know
politicians aren't in there qualify are
you talking about Prime for like child
support or are you talking about the
message the facts or Google it
it's it's always like some super
dysfunctional family on that set with
the drunk guy uh dad Don Lemon dad but
we want to take it seriously Don Lemon
said well he got this from Google so we
went to Google and we typed in an
obvious request show us the
quintessential specimen in his prime
and we're going to tell you what we
found we're not going to hide the
results full transparency on this show
it did not take us long to come across
pictures of Don Lemon himself
looking like the international sex
symbol he is at the age of 56. look at
this man look at those clothes this is a
is that a cape no it's got arms but it
could be a cape is that bold he's a
fashion icon then we came across these
Instagram posts showing Don Lemon on the
runway a few weeks ago we don't want to
use the word fabulous but is there
another word to describe it no there's
not ladies and gentlemen fabulous Don
Lamont
oh great and the word sassy does comes
to mind too in their Prime Don Lemon is
in his prime right now his lived
experience is being too sexy
was this whole segment a roundabout way
for Don Lemon to get everyone to Google
pictures of Donald we can't say
but as you can imagine the morning
meeting today at CNN was awkward CNN
forced Mr Lemon to zoom in the meeting
from Miami where he has been frolicking
shirtless on the beach looking very much
not coincidentally like a man in his
prime
and his apology he read what appeared to
be a cliche about women he had Googled
about three minutes before between
Bellini's here it is quote I believe
that women of any age can do whatever
they set their minds to
and you can just imagine in your mind
the ladies of the view holding him at
gunpoints say it don't say it at any age
an 80 year old can give birth
yeah it wasn't heartfelt uh not reality
based it was kind of ridiculous if
you're going to grovel do it he didn't
and apparently his co-workers and
managers at CNN are mad we're hoping he
comes back if if we lose Don Lemon we've
lost a major Wellspring of comedy in
this country
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight